I am the past the present and the future
all at once
boundless omniscience incarnate swirling
in the luminous plasma of a newborn star
I am doctor Manhattan welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my
watchmen HBO episode 2 video there were
so many references of doctor Manhattan so
many secret conspiracy reveals so we'll
break all the Easter eggs down if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything
we're doing an HBO now giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
episode on the video careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet will do top 10 and
Easter eggs so starting with number 10
the opening flashback to World War 1
explaining the origin story of Lou
Gossett Jr's old piece of paper that his
father gave to him when he was escaping
town during the original Tulsa
they referenced the typewriter that we
saw awesome and iasts typing on in last
week's episode there's a lot of
recurring themes so you see things show
up in present-day you see them show up
in the past that is not a coincidence
but we find out that it's just meant to
be German propaganda that the Kaiser was
giving to all the Allied forces and
african-americans trying to sow dissent
among the Allied ranks come to our side
you'll live this wonderful life it's
also a reference to the title of the
episode marshal feats of Comanche
horsemanship so that's actually the name
of a real-life painting that's hanging
inside the Chiefs house that's a
painting from real life that they just
used in the episode the artist George
Caitlin drew it as a reference to a
special military tactic they observed
the Comanche horsemen using to evade the
weapons of their enemies by dropping to
the side of the horse then coming back
up in changing quote-unquote to the
other side of the horse if necessary to
defeat their enemies that is very
clearly a reference to what the chief
was doing and what Lou Gossett Jr's
character was doing switching sides so
to speak to defeat their enemy so
suddenly it's super hard to tell which
side you're fighting on in all this
number 9 all the Doctor Manhattan
references during the first line of
questioning inside the secret bakery
Batcave the code to her safe is 1985 the
year of the original comic book she
rents a little bit of grief but you
notice the blue light of the coffeemaker
shining in the darkness that just
another Doctor Manhattan referenced there's
a lot of blue in scenes if you ever
notice something that's particularly
blue
typically that's their on purpose as a
doctor Manhattan reference we'll talk
about Ozymandias play with the very
notable blue person in it in a second
she doesn't learn completely who he is
till the end of the episode but then he
makes all these references to Doctor
Manhattan's powers maybe I'm Doctor
Manhattan he can make himself look like
a human he can grow he can change the
molecular structure of objects give off
energy blasts change the color of his
skin so even though he's kind of saying
it jokingly just kind of pushing her a
little bit during this conversation
remember that idea
Doctor Manhattan secretly making himself
look like other people because later in
the episode they referenced secret
identities when they're doing the
American hero story episode saying that
we wouldn't want to reveal that up front
we want to keep the viewer watching to
the very end of the finale that's just a
meta reference to real life in damon
lindelof in the watchmen HBO writers
wanting us the audience to keep watching
to the end like I said so many hidden
Doctor Manhattan references as if they want
you to think that he's secretly walking
around and were watching him in episodes
without realising that he's here on
planet earth already but they do
reference him being on Mars during her
conversation with her son but there's
even more Doctor Manhattan references
during that - when she's talking to him
trying to tell him that his uncle
quote-unquote the chief is dead and he
gets all upset he's actually building
this big structure that looks just like
the structure that Doctor Manhattan was
building on Mars with magnets some
special technology just really cool
space-age toys but you notice it also
kind of resembles the castle that
Ozymandias is currently living in in all
the scenes that we've seen him in so
everything is connected this is all on
purpose but Lou Gossett jr. gives her
the speech about this deep running
conspiracy that the chief is part of
this sets her on her quest during the
episode to find out what skeletons are
literally and metaphorically in her
closet number eight the conspiracy
theorists at the newsstand kind of tells
you what the episode is all about
he claims that President Robert Redford
is behind the raining baby squids to
distract people from what's really going
on so that they'll all be busy fighting
each other and they won't see what the
government is doing which is kind of a
metaphor for what's going on with the
storyline with the cavalry because it
sounds like the chief in this greater
conspiracy was meant to engineer all
this fighting that was going on in Tulsa
between the cavalry and the local
population so that they wouldn't pay
attention to what the government might
be doing like all this cavalry
is just a ruse nobody really cares about
it number seven was the flashback to the
actual white night when the cavalry
attacked them it's Christmas Eve you
noticed that the clock hits midnight the
Doomsday Clock reference when they
attack she has a real badass take down
but she almost gets and a lot of
you probably suspected what was really
going on with the chief when she passed
out looking at the Rorschach mask and
then woke up to the Chiefs face like
they wanted to visually tell you that he
was connected to the cavalry somehow he
seems really sure of himself when he's
telling her about everything and chuckin
Lee seems like he has a plan for the
police putting on masks when she says
that she doesn't want to quit well
shucks I guess I'm not going to quit either
what I think is going on here is that he
does have a soft spot for her but he's
clearly connected to this larger
conspiracy because the senator is at his
house later and he shows up in next
week's episode too so this goes way up
the government like Lou Gossett jr. says
there's this vast conspiracy you have no
idea it'll blow your mind they make all
kinds of references to the original
Watchmen series they go to the Nixon
ville there's literally a statue of
Nixon there with an original American
flag with only 50 stars on it because
remember there's 51 now because Vietnam
is an official part of the United States
but number 6 you guys all probably
recognize the Jim Bever cameo in the
tales of the black freighter references
so I think the idea is the Jim beaver is
the grandfather of her adopted children
they haven't completely explained how
she wound up adopting them but it's
probably connected to something related
to 7th cavalry stuff because he seems
like he kind of sympathizes with them
and they both really hate each other
clearly but when she walks into the
middle of their game they're talking
about ghosts they're talking about him
sinking to the bottom a pirate ship
that's all tales of the black freighter
the Nine Inch Nails music during the
episode was great too the piano track
that started playing during this scene
kind of sounded like hurt number 5 the
American hero story episode so pretty
much everybody in every different place
that they flashed to all over town even
the 7th cavalry members lookingglass in
his house Angela's family and her house
are watching this episode it's meant to
be a retelling of the adventures of the
original Minutemen
but the episode itself focuses on the
origin story of hooded justice so in the
comics they never tell you what his real
identity is but he's meant to be the
very first vigilante in the United
States during the comic book series some
of the present-day Watchmen are inspired
by him
put on the hood like you would read a
comic book and be inspired by a
superhero to eventually become a
superhero someday
the funny thing is those they kind of
tell you what his real identity is
because they never did that during the
comic book they say Ralph Mueller he was
a circus strongman the hooded justice
character in the comics was described as
a strongman so then they sort of slide
into the area of metaphor when he talks
about why he put the hood on why he was
looking for justice how he was never
quite sure of who he was when he was
looking in the mirror and is then
literally telling you why Angela put the
hood on because she's trying to hide all
this stuff she's not sure who she really
is she's looking for justice and earlier
in the episode when she's confronting
will and putting her costume on you see
the camera focus on her hood as she
pulls it over her head just like hooded
justice would put his hood on number
four though she cleverly engineers a
scenario to get herself into the Chiefs
bedroom so she can spy on him and finds
out that he was secretly a member of the
cavalry or at least connected to them or
behind them the reason why they make
note of the senator being there is
because his wife used to work with him
and they just want you to make the
connection oh the chief is somehow
connected to him and if he's behind this
big conspiracy that must mean that the
senator is also connected to this
conspiracy she's got some really badass
goggles but that's kind of them
reminding you that in this alternate
future they have this Doctor Manhattan
derivative technology that's way more
advanced than stuff that we have in
present-day
she walks out they zoom in on the
painting this named Marshall feats of
Comanche horsemanship which I already
explained but as the camera zooms in on
the white horse they transitioned to
Ozymandias back at that giant castle so
number three awesome Andy is his secret
play there were so many mind-blowing
reveals I love what Jeremy Irons is
doing with this character they revealed
that all of these people Thomas on and
the other helper are clones there's a
bunch of them would you like to be the
new mr. Hughes oh I would like it very
much sir right after he burns the last
clone alive without any sign of regret
so a lot of you were confused about the
horseshoe moment in last week's episode
why didn't he know it was a horseshoe
and a lot of people tried to make the
connection to Doctor Manhattan of the
original series so there's this comic
book panel Doctor Manhattan is slowly
losing his humanity in his connection
identifying human objects like he's
looking at a bra sitting in bed and he
doesn't realize what it is like what is
this thing that I'm holding again
because he
can't remember being human but part of
the reason why I think that he didn't
recognize the horseshoe is because he's
not completely all there up top but
earlier in the episode Lou Gossett
juniors character talks about how Doctor
Manhattan can create copies of himself
in wall this Doctor Manhattan play is going
on in Ozymandias house you have all
these different copies of people so many
more Doctor Manhattan references I'm sure
it's going to be the same thing in next
week's episode - it's going to be crazy but
very clearly the play the watchmakers
son is literally the origin story of Doctor
Manhattan that they're telling I both
loved and hated that he burned the Clone
as part of it like he didn't even
bother to pretend no we're going to waste
this one to make the play more authentic
he has a couple lines of dialogue that
are pretty important so he says nothing
ever ends and then when he's talking
about getting the watch back did it stop
sir no it's only just begun is the watch
continues to tick down to 12 midnight
just referencing the episodes of the
season it's going to finally hit midnight
by the time we get to the finale and
it's all about Ozymandias his new plan
because he says when is a lie not a lie
when is acting so there's something
going on with his storyline him acting
sort of reliving the same day over and
over again for a reason I'm sure you
already have a thousand theories about
what's going on with that but number two
she finds out that Lou Gossett jr. is
secretly her grandfather so he really
just wants to meet her and bring her in
and show her everything that she came
from all this history but the even
crazier ending number one he says he
has friends in high places he literally
has friends in high places because he
gets rescued by a helicopter magnet that
just carries him off it he's just kind
of laughing and chuckling to himself the
whole way through there was a really
cool Beastie Boys track two played over
the end credits - but clearly he has
something to do with his larger
conspiracy that the government is
enacting he's connected to those people
with those crazy resources because who
else would be able to send something
like that to go pick him up and
literally carry the car he was in off so
everybody posts all your conspiracy
theories about what's really going on in
the comments below
but episode 3 will be next week
congratulations Jose Zee you're the
giveaway winner from my last big
watchmen video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details everyone click here
for my watchmen episode 1 video and
click here for my brand-new Witcher
Netflix trailer Easter eggs and release date
thank you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!